We are under attack.
The demon hand of censorship
strikes again.
Opposables, we all know
censorship is a powerful weapon
that should only be used
against a real threat,
like Democratic memos
or that eye exam poster
that has the secret
deep state message in it.
But we should never censor
Internet truth.
Look at this latest assault on
one of our alt-media brethren.
REPORTER:
YouTube starting to crack down
on a controversial channel.
Reports say it gave
an Infowars channel
its first strike
for sharing various theories
about the school shooting
in Florida.
YouTube is trying to cut down
on hate speech and fake news
by permanently banning accounts
with three strikes
in three months.
What?
Three strikes and you're out?
Nothing could be less American.
-(applause)
-But this,
this is where we are.
YouTube claims they gave
Infowars their first strike
because they are violating
their content policy
by spreading "hate speech
and fake news."
But that's fake news.
Infowars has been truth-telling
like this for years,
since lizard people first
demanded immigration rights.
I mean, look!
What is your take
on-on Sandy Hook?
All the people that look
and act like actors.
I'm sorry, folks,
this is such a false flag.
This was such an attempt
to make Trump look bad.
You look at the Aurora shooting.
That was totally staged.
Alex Jones says the things
no one else would,
because only he dares
to stoop so brave.
(laughter)
That's why the establishment
comes after him like this.
Everyone has it in
for Alex Jones.
CNN, MSNBC, cholesterol.
(laughter)
And now there's a new narc
yapping at his heels.
And a few days ago,
Jones called him out by name.
Jordan Keppler.
What's his name?
MAN:
Josh Keppler or something?
The.... And I don't just act,
like, cool,
like I don't know who he is.
I don't watch.
This Keppler guy.
There are ten shows we know of--
Homeland, Keppler--
who attack us
five nights a week,
and who say things
we never said.
Keppler is... is-is-is again,
like the classic psychopath
in school,
and he's just lording
and enjoying the lies.
Keppler is a failed actor.
So he's another dropping
of Soros.
Yeah. You heard that, right?
There's a failed actor out there
on Comedy Central
who's attacking Alex Jones, and
his name is... Jordan Keppler.
(laughter)
This guy sounds like a dick.
Oh, he's handsome for a soy-boy,
I'll give him that.
(laughter)
You look at that guy,
and you see Armie Hammer
without all the flashy muscles
and the grandstanding jawbone,
you know?
He's got a forehead
that goes all the way up.
But don't be fooled.
This guy is bad news.
He's deep state.
I did a little digging,
and if he's an actor,
why does IMDB claim
he does not exist?
(laughter)
Because Keppler is too smart.
He scrubbed the database.
But Alex Jones never lets a
total lack of evidence stop him
from reporting the truth.
Here's the crazy thing.
Jones is upset
because this Jordan Keppler
criticized Infowars
for reporting
crisis actors were employed
after the Parkland shooting,
the same claims that got him
his first YouTube strike.
And what's even more wild--
the same night this Keppler guy
was attacking Infowars,
our show,
hosted by me, Jordan Klepper,
was very sincerely defending
Infowars for that same story.
(laughter)
This Keppler is a disgusting,
deep-state mole.
Also, it sounds like he has
some real gastric problems.
The point is, is that
diarrhea coming out
of a wart-infested butt,
Keppler, uh, is a joke.
I mean, this is a parasite
that reads off a teleprompter.
Diarrhea coming out
of somebody's ass.
A tumor in your MRI.
Let's go back to turd blossom.
Here's Lord Keppler.
Yeah. Whoa. It sounds...
To be fair, it sounds gross,
but turd blossoms were actually
the flowers at my first wedding.
(laughter)
Clearly, Jones knows
how to win an argument.
But what I worry about is
that the folks at YouTube
won't listen to reason.
If left unchecked, this Keppler
might draw attention
to other Infowars videos
that YouTube could use
as an excuse to ban them.
Things like,
"PROOF! Boston Marathon Bombing
is Staged Terror Attack," or
"The Orlando Shooting
Was A False Flag," or
"The War On Male Vitality
Exposed: Special Report."
(laughter)
Hard-hitting reporting.
The fact is, Alex Jones is
facing a potential ban
from YouTube because
of the things his show said.
Now, is that his fault? No!
It's the fault
of people like Jordan Keppler.
Opposers,
don't let the mainstream media
and Keppler win.
Can't pay off
your student loans?
Well, who's choice was it
to major in musical poetry?
Blame Keppler!
Someone farted in the elevator
you're alone in?
Blame Keppler!
He's literally made of diarrhea!
Get your YouTube channel
shut down
for violating their policy
on hate speech,
thus drastically reducing
your vitamin supplement
revenue stream?
-Blame Keppler!
-(laughter, applause)
Opposers,
we need to spread the word.
Tweet @RealAlexJones
all the things
that Jordan Keppler has ruined
so he knows
to hashtag "blame Keppler."
Because if there's not
a shadowy figure on the horizon
who you can blame
all your problems on,
then the problem is you.
And that sounds like
some crazy conspiracy theory.
(laughter)